oui tout à l'heure françois mitterrand a
évoqué à l'elysée l'évolution en
allemagne de l'est il s'est réjoui des
changements que vont sans doute qu'ils
vont sans doute résulter du départ de
monsieur necker et le président
mitterrand a évoqué l'éventualité d'une
réunification des deux allemagne et
goûter un changement d'homme
généralement le signe que l'on commence
à bouger sur le fond quel est le degré
de réflexion des responsables de
l'allemagne de l'est
je ne peux pas se voir c'est dans la
logique même de l'histoire et d'imaginer
que le peuple allemand ne sera pas et
gardez-les m'en séparer de cette façon
et quand je dis éternellement sipa pour
renvoyer à la chine à cette éventualité
et j'ai le situer dans le temps et qui
toutes manières sacré dans les
préoccupations contemporaines des
responsables de la politique
internationale spécialement de la
politique européenne
un changement d'homme est généralement
le signe que l'on commence à bouger sur
le fond quel est le degré de réflexion
des responsables d'al allemagne de l'est
je ne peux pas se voir c'est dans la
logique même de l'histoire de d'imaginer
que le peuple allemand ne sera pas
éternellement séparer de cette façon et
quand je dis éternellement c'est pas
pour renvoyer à l'infini cette
éventualité qui je ne peut situer dans
le temps mais qui toutes manières
s'inscrit dans les préoccupations
contemporaines des responsables de la
politique internationale spécialement de
la politique européenne